challenges and opportunities are for
Latin America clearly there for me there
are three main ones that we can consider
and summarize pretty well what time we
need to deliver in the region the first
one has to do with fostering and the
letter developing more education because
it's the way to reduce poverty and it's
also there the way to improve the
inclusion of people the social coin
shape the second one has to do with
consolidate their the motor cut
Democratic regimes that will bring to
each one of the country's the stability
that is required from a political
perspective but also from an economical
perspective this consolidation will
bring security and terms of regulation
in terms of the loss of different
countries that will foster the
investment side before investments in
the region and the third one is clearly
related to the building on the strengths
of the radio the junk population is a
lot of passion is a huge capability of
innovation and we are absolutely sure
that we need to continue the investments
to increase our presence in the common
sector had also including the technology
and communication sector so as a summary
allocation to reduce poverty in the
increase social cohesion consolidate the
democratic regimes to accelerate the
economical stability and the frameworks
that allow businesses to develop and the
third one to build on the strengths by
continue to invest in infrastructure
including in that infrastructure
information technology and
communications as a key driver for the
transformation of Bloody Mary